Here are five free certifications that every student needs on their resume.
Number one is Google AI Essentials.
This is the number one skill that many employers are looking for right now and Google will
certify this for you for free.
And the best part is you can complete it in under two hours.
The second one is HubSpot Digital Marketing.
This free certification is recognized by nearly every employer and it only takes around five hours to complete.
The third one is GitHub Foundations.
This certificate proves to employers that you know the one tech tool that nearly every company uses.
So fourth one is IBM Skills Bill.
This is a cyber security certification that is not only free but also gives you 12 college credits.
And the last one is the Cloud Certified Architect Certification.
This one is of course highly relevant right now and companies are even paying their employees
thousands of dollars just to complete it.
If you simply comment, resume down below, I'll send you the link of all of these plus 20 more certifications.